I think no I just think that this is you
now you should have better service to
the people on you now yeah give our
undivided time detention seek for number
one where are those you know people who
are number one on Johnny's we don't need
people to actually be watching we don't
need no stinking badges we don't need no
stinking badges audience yeah one viewer
three viewers three Tamiko reactors in
the house three Tamiko reactor that's my
Kenny G right there yo what does that
mean Brendan v he's always here just a
little ready to dougie us Brendan V go
back to the chat ok here we go people
talking yet no one still no one's
talking no one's talking where's that
Thursday 10pm crowd there you go Brennan
Cordero in the house he didn't you
didn't say hi Greg he says hi that's hot
ok we're cracking open window it's hot
hey guys hey dumb see DOM hey Brendan
career Cordero it's greg nice to meet
you officially i like to say thank you
for tuning in to our you now account he
noted Dom see any dominant [ __ ] you're
gonna have plenty of more of those kind
of jokes here at the real rejects I'm
Greg this is john this is john it's 130
there in the afternoon or the morning
renan be no one needs to sleep dirty
birdie Damon that is Matt Damon personal
you now account and he clearly loves the
channel dirty he clearly left the
channel or it could be damon albarn guys
um just let you know front we're
primarily just gonna pay attention to
you now because we're doing it through
here and we are planning on doing more
sketches officially so whatever you guys
donate today will help go towards those
kind of projects yes it will that's
mainly what they're going for we want to
actually have good quality with them so
that will require paying people for
their services and you guys are
course we're going to take notice of the
ones who help donate the one to help
raise we will credit you yeah we should
like people in the credits which is like
right these days yeah whoever donates
you should put them in the credits yeah
yeah we're going to try and make we're
going to try to up the value of our
sketches and also up the value of these
live streams here you know we're gonna
get some sound equipment we're gonna see
if we can get some actual video
equipment says a lot of stuff bookmarked
on amazon for what we want to get if you
want to me that is a good quality for
you guys that's how many people are in
the audience here let's see 72 Mueller's
we got 17 viewers that's great that's
great you know that makes us feel really
good hey guys E&M we don't believe in
product placement hey Dom see wants to
know your fan better call Saul I like
the first season I haven't seen any of
the second season like Jonah w I played
every uncharted game you should know
this by now every single one twice Italy
twice at least oh my god we just came
I'm not blaming twice sometimes two in
an app to see Tycho leg thank you for
the hundred-plus likes you're an awesome
man alright guys we're gonna kick this
off let's do a warm-up story here a
warm-up story John has an ember of you
any of the ones i've bookmarked nope but
it's okay so we're just gonna read
headlines and we're gonna go off that
you're gonna take the lead ryan gosling
in case you guys don't notice I'm a big
Ryan Gosling fan as a matter of fact as
I was showering today I imagine bumping
into him let's say like a menchies or
something and having like my camera and
being like Ryan I please get you on
camera I have a youtube channel huge fan
of him like doing a little bit me I
think that'd be really cool that
happened one thing yeah so really likes
frozen yogurt anyway Ryan Gosling we're
gonna be at every store in the Los
Angeles areas at some point getting
yogurt he's confirmed to star in gaming
shows else he is the guy who did kids
guys don't see that yeah whiplash who
wrote 10 Cloverfield Lane two he has a
credit on that yeah a good for him I
think the guy it's fair to say that he's
a little talented you know a little bit
he's got some skill he's almost I to
make an impression in Holly
what who knows anyway neil armstrong
biopic first man he skies no Neil
Armstrong is he's the guy who had
testicular cancer and won the Tour de
France yeah get it it's less thick
strong same time you guys a comedy and
stop tonight never you know as a matter
of fact we don't have that you now page
open and we can't read the comments I
feel like I can just really say whatever
I long if I can't read it go and say I
mean gonna be effective I want any of
the comments / technically say whatever
you want whatever yeah I could totally
doesn't matter um is interesting doing
Neil Armstrong by oh yeah shaselle said
that it's a mission movie and it's my
co-writer of spotlight and I thought a
movie about children being less in the
Catholic Church first man on the Moon
totally perfect combination hearse man
correlation I could see the correlation
but yeah I mean look at this picture
Neil Armstrong he does look like I feel
like Ryan Gosling could pull it off and
I feel like he commits to the haircut
dude it'd be sad is he right now so much
like it would be sad to see Ryan Gosling
not uh you know with his sexy ass hair
but hey that's thank you that's as part
of the sacrifice and I think any alarm
strong movie is it wasn't it proven that
that moon landing was faked no Reuben
it's a popular conspiracy theory some
people believe that Stanley Kubrick
directed the moon landing no i don't
know if that's real is George Lucas yeah
George Luke was making not use became of
the story but but hey oh my god we got
bars got sample we've got some possible
before God thank you guys Brendan v8v
inch as always next well justin Maxwell
you guys are so kind to actually start
writing down some dude it's so kind of
their helping out with us anything you
guys donate is being invested back into
better equipment so we can do better
live streaming and so we can have money
funded to help do projects like sketches
and short films so thank you guys so
much anyway I think Ryan
rustling is the best actor around right
now I think he is that's definitely one
of the finest of our generation yeah I
mean he might not always like change his
voice and changed but well he's to me
he's one of those he's one of those
mannerisms guys were like even if he
doesn't like drastically changed his
appearance and his you know voice and
stuff he usually takes on different
mannerisms and characteristics yeah that
were you know he's good at getting into
character holy crap breanne from Miss
movies is good [ __ ] here guys if you
haven't seen us yet on the hitter miss
miss channel you gotta go check out John
and I each did a film therapy session
and we did six degrees and feature film
segment with anthurium Stacey how were
they're both incredibly sexy women and
if there was such an honor to talk with
sexy woman with brains you don't see
that often you know you don't rather one
or the other it's black or white out
there I mean color like in people i mean
like you know what I mean okay anyway
okay let's look at some of that other
comments in you now let's look at some
of the comments Jason Bourne is Greg
Alva that's true Danielle d is here
Daniel D it's so lovely to see your
lovely profile picture here in the
Kremlin yesterday again you are
absolutely stunning I must say just just
an M we love your videos I'm your number
one subscriber so thank you I wish the
comments just didn't keep like
automatically going down yeah whenever
in two jossen like asked us a question a
very important question any plans of
reviewing the Korean film the handmaiden
or all I've heard it's great brain to
Busan yeah those uh both of those have
popped up on a lot of like top 10 horror
movies of the Year lists and I really
want to see them
haven't got a chance to yet training
sean is supposed to be amazing and I've
heard a lot of good ones for what was
that called the veil uh I I forgot you
know okay I completely forgot in the
Commerce yeah I moving way too fast I've
heard both of those are really good i
want to see them um oh yeah we did the
josh mokuba show we were off Joshua
cougar show recently to you guys you
gotta watch that a lot of funny it was a
fun interview I think I think that one
will definitely make you guys laugh if
you don't you don't have a sense of
humor you can find out a lot of
uncomfortable things about our sex lives
hey Logan el battles is a fellow
youtuber here you know what we got to
help each other out fellow youtubers
everyone look he has the best YouTube
channel Logan el battles look who does
Logan el battles Logan el batal he takes
female action figures and has them fight
each other in a claymation format this
is real said yeah it's an amazing
channel that's that's friggin awesome
let's see Harriette L from New Zealand
Floyd Kunkle it's it's like you're
pirates and curvy don't good no it is
just a comic own codes handmaiden that's
what it was hanmi yeah I've heard thank
you guys thank you um hey so let's talk
about the big 12 everyone's you know
really struck by this this where it
didn't go no no no secret I'm like am
looking for everyone's talking about
that Mendelsohn horse and crawling man
oh it's something special freezer
there's a new movie by far own spin-off
series it's gonna be not i made an
article for this Carrie Fisher hand away
Carrie Fisher and carrie fisher's mother
yeah oh my goodness that's terrible I
you know like I'm really happy Carrie
Fisher got to make it a return
appearance in the force awakens I don't
know people were like follow the force
awakens yes yeah
did you think I was sorry i was thinking
of rogue Wonka's people from talking
about about well you know what I was
okay with her appearance in Road one I
thought it was fine and it's cool that
she gotta come back in the spotlight
again and remind everyone about how like
how iconic her role was and stuffy like
she didn't get like four people who
didn't even probably know her name but
just knew his princess later really
actually got to know her name it was
nice to have a hell yeah Princess Leia
moment yes be like oh yeah presence' all
right like you know I forgot how much I
missed her so like you know cuz cuz I
haven't watched the original films in a
while it's like yeah I was excited to
see her in the force awakens it's sad
man I mean I my my dad passed away for I
mean he likes survived a few heart
attacks he passed away from like real
failure like 56 I think 57 some were
there and to lose a woman so young who I
heard that she did finish her shooting
on the next star wars movie but they you
know they still needed a dr and maybe
reshoots and stuff so only tricky
they'll figure it out I think they have
a way where you can CGI someone's face
once yeah and I think it goes down well
every time they do but every time
there's no reason to think it wouldn't
go down well with very Fisher yeah
exactly I don't know if it would be to
sue might be offensive at that moment
you know um yeah yeah no I'm put but to
lose Carrie Fisher and then like and
then Debbie Reynolds like just a day or
two later like it almost feels like just
someone's writing this like it's it's
surreal it's weird a lot of celebrity
deaths this year man and for whatever
reason I don't I was I didn't know
enough about them to know so when I
heard Debbie Reynolds was like oh she
did Reynolds owns like it's carrie
fisher's mom and I was like what
remember when we remember when we were
much younger and I used to just talk
about wanted to be sad yes I acted to go
to be seven Jackie Chan dies one day oh
thank you so much hrj just tweeted about
our stream continue you can just hold
that thought I think go by I was going
over a memory yeah yeah when you used to
bring up early
depressing hypothetical scenarios famous
people dying or my dog you asked me
about my dog and my mom I think my dad
my sister you asked me about like did I
most of the important people that I've
been very least my dog it may be one of
my family members well how right was I
when ya what I was pretty sad man is
crazy were right on the money yeah I is
uncanny it's hard to deal with first
thing I thought of a pun that death was
like Greg is right I'm gonna have to buy
him a drink that it's such a weird
experience when we lose a celebrity you
know because especially a celebrity that
we actually really admire in you know it
makes an impact because we don't
technically know these people but we've
spent time with them and who invested in
their work well you don't people still
talk about all my god I can't repeat
Fletcher's dead you know it's been so
many years and people still are like ah
what you do at the thing is like
especially with actors and end stuff and
even people you see just you know who
are celebrities for whatever reason like
with actors and musicians they connect
to us an emotional level because that's
their instrument so like a beloved
character and you know Carrie Fisher to
was was you know like you know a member
of society you know I mean she stood up
for a lot of things like she used her
position for good things so like a lot
of people felt so it's weird i saw
status that very day somebody was saying
like you know i had a real death in my
family and y'all are [ __ ] around
being mad about something that has no
effect on your life and doesn't matter I
was like well I don't know I mean like I
when Anton Yelchin died I was I was
actually like I felt it for the first
time cuz usually went when celebrities
die like I'm adjusted the point where
I'm like yeah that's I'm bummed to hear
that but you know it's it's not like I
spend a lot of time ruminating on it but
way I felt that with with him for the
first time where I was like well this
this cast a shadow over like the next
several days like I I still think about
it sometimes and you know they're part
of your life in a sense especially Star
Wars like so many people have started
film career or just you know started
their love of movies with star for her
so
yeah her death or david bowie's dit like
these things have to hit you a little
bit because you're bonded to their art
you know I mean Alex wz said why only
beloved celebrities thought what about
Kardashian Trump or Bieber why those
kind of never die it's because the
Lannisters always win the Lannister
Lannisters always pay their debts and I
just stick around and no one can take
those [ __ ] Han yeah evil
prevails people and I good wins don't
worry they'll have their time too if you
really want them to talk but ok I've in
one day well I don't know maybe it's not
as widely publicized not as many people
more with like trouble more troubled
people go you know like because it's
where your leg away slippers become like
culture memes especially now like where
everyone it's a conversation everyone
can join into not just the immediate
group of friends that you see ya know
like so I don't hey the frozen flame
donated 15 bars whoo hey mrs. 15 bar I
really appreciate it man we really
appreciate it look let's answer a couple
of questions we'll move on to our move
more movie news um okay this one speed
round xavy r07 what's your favorite
movie it was the matrix does this is
lightning round one and done are we
allowed to show face cam what do you
mean was that mean yeah get your face in
their voice nerd Thank You boys nurse
Saudi chem why does Greg always have new
girlfriends because you can't tie this
God down man oh yeah he's dating
everyone dating every one of them I am
romantically involved with every female
you've ever seen amber over there okay
with it man they all know the deal
they're like you're worth it Greg so how
many shorter than this arrangement is
fair to me as well as it is to you the
nickname took forever how high are you
right now how high are you look just
because I'm getting defensive doesn't
mean I'm really high I'm just asking you
why would you ask me such a
question I'm not getting defensive suck
a toe for 10 minutes we'll listen to
nickelback for 24 hours oh well what's
the state of the toe yeah whose toe is
it Stacy Howard's talento do I get to be
like yo yet you wash your toe like fine
ten minutes not that events whose toe
we're talking about and it's not like
like nickelback doesn't bother me that
much just like 24 hours would get a lot
older than 10 minutes on toe I could
listen to 10 minutes or nickelback
unless he was like a nasty as toe which
case the eldest nickelback golden okay
important question Liam talky poop
toilet paper do you fold or crumble fol
fold I used to my Master's older one I
don't what crumble crumbling yet Paris
not teach you manners sorry I learned
later yo voice nerd donated 35 bars he's
the number one fan y'all gonna try to
beat him out he might get top billing
when we give special thanks to a man
here are the villain if we're ever in
San Diego will let you know we can all
meet up like we're hoping it would be
awesome if these can get big enough or
we could just have like a meetup at like
a pub somewhere that'd be pretty cool we
should do that spill guys could do it we
can do it too um Greg going back to
morbidity whose death would you would
make you more sad ryan gosling of bryan
cranston oh right cause I agree Gosling
would probably make me more sad actually
I met Bryan Cranston twice while he was
working on knock him in the middle nice
guy like two times in the same afternoon
no I on different different days weeks
apart just make sure that would be
staying Ryan Gosling they're both gonna
be sad Who am I gonna be more sad about
I guess I'll to tell you when they both
died ask me again when they both died
but they both have to be dead you ever
travel to New Zealand uh if yeah if I
was allowed to like bring a flamethrower
dude sadiq em says who's the best
canadian actor now I love to travel to
New Zealand actually my old bosses from
New Zealand Ryan Gosling who's the best
actor right now canadian actor canadian
actor right now oh yeah probably who
else is getting boring
coaxing Greg are you gonna make more
video song edits what does that mean
what our video song is Joe 2w wanna know
how does it feel in the moment meeting a
celeb it depends on the celebrity that
you're talking to yeah if it's tom
holland if it's tom holland he's a
cold-hearted did you know what I really
thought about my time when I met Tom
Paula what I row because I didn't meet
Tom Holland Tom Holland MIT tyrone and
we're there haunting that Tyrone it I'm
the one you got excited to see tamil I
shout him you're Tom Holland ain't even
like say anything to me well I thought I
was like Tyrone's groupie friend or will
be friends with a big youtuber so those
are my friend Lola step up Heisenberg
gosh Danielle d a favorite drink um i
love i love a good alkaline water 9.5
those delicious and i like i like core
kuroda extra a lot gotta get that corona
extra in there and a nice hard lemonade
from mike have a soft spot in my heart
for mike's oh yeah i'll do another music
I was just thinking about doing another
when I do a compilation with thumbs I
was just thinking about doing that today
I was thinking another 51 did you really
not know any men I don't know any man
I'd like you're a gentleman oh I'm glad
you want to see more of those do you
that makes me feel good that it's not
about a [ __ ] reaction something else
thanks man oh that's really good have
you tried Victoria was Victoria I don't
know Victoria haven't tried her yet what
sort of music are you both in 20 well
John is really in to like country reggae
I'm more into why it's a classical pop
you know well answer my questions in a
second pletely I John Logan will not
feature a Deadpool cameo as confirmed by
Ryan Reynolds yeah but then again who
knows it's Deadpool pouring the sauce
typically i wanna maybe Wade Wilson yeah
yeah I mean I think it could it could
work I think it'd be distracting for
Logan's last outing I think you'll be
like they're they exist in such
different universes and the only way i
can see that actually working as if Wade
Wilson had some kind of like small role
in the movie again like just having seen
Civil War yesterday you know it's like
yeah you can cram I'm through I'm fairly
convinced you can cram in a character as
long as you decide to spend a little
time with them but at least for me from
the outside I don't I don't think I
think from her I think this is what look
this is Hugh Jackman's last outing I
feel people might get to psych them dunk
example with that [ __ ] yeah yeah the
same time for [ __ ] you know crossover
conundrum [ __ ] I feel like if we can
focus up and take it easy on one movie
this one like this is Hugh Jackman like
he's going out like this movie deserves
to be like every single thing that wants
to be and nothing that yes is gonna be
weighed down by marketing scheme guys
guys I gotta tell you I gotta tell you
John saw captain america civil war last
yeah finally got him to watch the movie
and for my understanding John he liked
it yeah I believe he liked it a lot I
did like I believe anybody was fantastic
I thought it was pretty awesome tacular
and it was awesome tackler Chris Duncan
says that yeah yeah and like for real
like I think I'm gonna remember it which
is nice like I think I'm a button look
Sadiq em who is the best actress right
now clearly Jennifer Lawrence or
Scarlett Johansson it's got every one of
those two I mean Jennifer Lawrence Kan
can turn in a good performance like I've
seen I've seen less performances by
scarlett johansson where I'm like
remarkable but I have seen a few where I
am like remarkable so you know I don't
think they're necessarily the best
though right now ya zine says you know
Greg you might find a celebrity who's a
fan of your channel I happen to know Ray
Liotta loves this jay is all about Ray
Liotta is constantly on this [ __ ] him
and Pesci constantly I decided scene
from Goodfellas but when after
says he's a you think I'm funny he's
like now cuz it knocks the real rejects
they're funny cuz they both love us yeah
ok just like that enjoy i got so great
I'm use you do you think any DC this
would be good I just like the way that
kept questions dent assoc be fair you
don't just do reactions i love how you
intro a video yes thank you and you
analyze the video thanks man thanks i
like to give all my thanks to
blasphemous HD thank you no thank you ok
do you guys think Breaking Bad spinoff
with Jesse we boring what would be
really interesting I could see a Jesse
siminoff happen after breaking down or
that pretty cool [ __ ] yeah after
breaking bad i could see them doing that
yeah and especially since better call
Saul is like an altogether different
show I feel like if they did that yeah
we gotta change his life back together
after the worst treatment hook like any
now character like yeah that probably be
interesting like let's see ya um well
scott jenkins 98 SJ took the thousand
bars write his name down my friend next
sketch you got everyone who donates a
day getting a shout out of her next
sketch we have a good way we wrote up a
strip for it we do t Tabata for it so
that's that's the thing right now
alright bless we just like talking about
movie news interacting with you
[ __ ] scott jenkins I appreciate
that we once had a friend named Carter
Jenkins start on the NBC hit show
surface in start of the netflix movie
circle oh isn't circle he's in circle so
thank you Scott any Jenkins as a friend
Borat cult coax is it donate a thousand
bars oh man you are way too kind Borat
Coulson you know Borat was a great movie
by Sasha Aaron stark
who what is this kid did the movie about
a guy who's gay from Austria does the
boar I character yes who um he did all
these I'll get all right is tajuk stam
guy wow you just interrupted my joke
blame is Rob les miserables let me sit
18 when you were like learning him
problem me did you reach ought to just
cut me off and just do another jokes no
bud right I was trying to get Borat a
special joke or a coke sent for doing a
thousand bar so sorry Laura cuz he just
has our peers ha interrupt me everybody
take your baggage in sarcasm somebody
sent to slim for the rain short film
dude that is so kind who's your favorite
director my favorite director Martin
Scorsese is eerily yeah not Mel Gibson
no ok so i dun like four films or five I
guess that's enough to warrant a
favorite Harriet area doubt tipped a
thousand artery and lay ariat lane thank
you so much I've been down that Lane my
friend and it is a hairy one I will tell
you my drop oh boy my draw let's look at
some news no John I saw some questions
come Harriet Lane you better throw in a
question so we can answer everyone who
donated a thousand bars throw in a
question Oh be the first ones to get
answered you understand you understand
me do you understand Ron Howard's your
favorite I guess that's an all right
director I mean have you seen his latest
films inferno whatever happened a brandy
price even primarily lives in Texas now
tejas really oh uh Daniel D are you guys
going to do more filipino videos yeah
you betcha ya see this for looking or
nose see it's got the pointy Italian
side let's also got the Filipino curve
here I'm glad you've studied
alio Wallace's Jennifer Lawrence a good
choice for poison ivy or black canary no
no no I don't want to see her in any
more comic book movie yeah that's a
horrible horrible suggestion how dare
you joined us you now broad yeah I'm
joking thank you for asking I look like
a smoker what is that like a cigarette
smoker or something else John smokes
many a crack pipes a day then his mom is
watching I want a minute who is your
favorite composer easily easily nine
inch nails that's not about choice I
mean like he makes interesting scores
they're always testing me John Williams
makes the best scores no I mean there
are guys like LeSean shimmer or like
Mark Isom or Michael Giacchino did you
choose it does me good stuff you guys
start reviewing shows I'm not sure about
that if I do like season premieres and
season finales I don't know about
reviewing an entire show honestly it's
just like how do you like review at all
every don't want to review every episode
I kind of like just watching a show for
my own pleasure yeah I feel like I have
to do a video about it like I think we
could we might like some day we might be
compelled to like review a season of a
show by would ya want to refuse
something an episode at a time like hey
Billy Lawrence and you again for Dion
Phaneuf you Miami make me feel like a
sexy stripper you know like you just you
don't even want me to strip you just
want to give me money because you think
i'm that special you know I'm that kind
of stripper I'd be a great stripper guys
did you the best strip right now except
for me Sondheim not bad John yes I don't
know if you know this was Scarlett
Johansson is the highest grossing actor
of 26 teen that's cool primarily thanks
to captain america civil war the other
highest-grossing actors are chris evans
and robert downey jr margot robbie way
lizra devil is Margot Robbie okay Amy
Adams Ben Affleck Henry Cavill Ryan
Reynolds will smith fall
none of those people was not in a comic
yes that's sure they're all comic book
me that's crazy except for except for
Felicity Jones yeah and that's style I
mean eight hours live behind if not a
coma for eight hundred five millions a
lot of money ottoman that's a lot of
money to make I mean she's set for life
now hopefully I'm if she's I mean if
she's she's smart what she will do is
kid maybe eight hundred million dollars
it will be smart as if she only chooses
to do roles that will make her money now
I'd rather be a Jedi because they seem a
lot more home um my opinion of the
casting of the han solo movie I just
think that you know casting Danny Glover
was a little bit of an odd choice
instead of going for a young Lando denge
in you here yeah they're going for a
young window then cats Danny Glover it's
crazy man funny but it's getting too old
for this [ __ ] evanni all right they
should write that it's like a line yo
den GN gave us a thousand bars den GN
you know you know what I'm gonna look up
what the word ng means is that different
that's different from Billy hill right
with Billy Oh somebody else just sounds
a den G is a Japanese burning
electro-magnetic that's cool my friend
you can do some real damage the matrix
ooh and that is that is sexy deji you
know just knowing that's her name makes
me feel drawn to you how do we need to
know who you are or what you look like I
just know they're magnetic 0 here 0 the
villain as well hero the village at the
thousand bars you know you can either
live long enough to see yourself become
the villain or die a hero didn't you say
that a little bit cooler if you're
flipping around like how we did any
movie did you say that to me during the
spider-man home can we trailer is that
you can I don't think I South Michael
Keaton you're the diet hero or you live
like I'm you see you something else no
that was just I think I was like a meme
or something okay plot twist the end of
the mega guys are donating seriously
it's really kind of you yeah thank you
so much seriously we're gonna
to get used so many comments are coming
how many people are watching I like you
thought twist 40 viewers yeah yeah I
like plot twists in the middle of the
movie actually like they're harder to
pull off but I also feel like if you can
hell yeah it's also my favorite Star
Wars character you know I don't feel Jar
Jar gets enough credit I had a lollipop
as a child it looked like a jar jar when
you opened it up his tongue was the
actual lollipop and that was disturbing
hindsight but he was my favorite
character for a while there I mean Jar
Jar was so underrated and he was meant
if I'm not mistaken he was meant to
appeal to more black people that was the
goal right I'm sorry that wasn't too
much i've said worse come on huh just a
blank conscious that you did Blake out
almost like I have no recollection of
you having said anything for the past
month guys look I want to take this
moment to share with the Ike's bro you
wait you made I am Dante put an egg down
his paper that's sketch man that's right
Greg and John we can't give thoughts on
the inning of lala land thank you jah
shaka for not being that if when
Princess Leia shows up it's just totally
awkward it's like what is she doing it
stems it's weird I she like jazz why'd
she take time I visited this play people
are responding to my little chargers
okay good oh we lost the viewer after I
said it though yeah damn day actions
speak louder than Jar Jar how would you
feel if road one didn't kill everyone in
the end why would I spoiler over a
question right there how would you feel
if Han Solo did it die begin to force a
week uh I I would just feel less
strongly about that as I love it it
reminded me of like a classic film there
might be a vote a real movie like
Magnificent Seven or Butch Cassidy and
the Sundance Kid you kill off your
characters well I mean like
the only make out or devils rejects you
only make one well of rejects is part
two but you know what i mean i thought
it was refreshing if everyone has lived
i just would be like okay cool i know
i'll see these characters again so i
don't have to work too hard to remember
them it's all about Bayes man Hayley
I'll Shinedown en hey base is super
sweet though he supported her that's
messed up that's that stuff yeah I heard
that um I heard that she was supposed to
live actually uh who listed he Jones and
she was she has it in her contract to
being more Star Wars movies what they
decided to kill her off Oh Brendan be
tipped a thousand Brendan v why did I
always trying to get into someone's v
right now you know what I mean that you
know that's what they call right yeah I
don't know the right damn 1 i'm all
about the pennis who would I rather be
dead pool or Wolverine Oh Deadpool maybe
Deadpool oh well I don't know I'm much
rather be dead will ring got those cool
shops though I mean like wait is so cool
yeah i feel like if i could be
Wolverines powers and abilities with my
personality IV sem yeah if I was ya
think it's like I would rather be dead
pool if I had to do like that guy cause
he's have a great time but I wouldn't
want to look like dead cool yes problem
is you would have to be able [ __ ] up
yeah I want to look that way I feel like
my books are the only good thing I got
about yes the only not my personality
humor it's only my looks the best known
reason why people like me you know you
know yeah totally John there aren't
really many new stories oh you click
back here this is all your doing all
right guys Harriet Lane whoa you are the
barn acid Lake Harriet who are you are
you it you're uh you're a hobbit from
new zealand new zealand oh dude Harriet
Lane you know I've always wanted to go
out with a new zealand girl
they've always been my favorite type of
girls you Zealand Jews and New Zealand's
a new zealand G or you're one of those
whose that would be ott and uz that
would be odd Logan L battles what's your
number one favorite baby of 2016 are you
guys ready for our number one favorite
movie or 2016 all right here's what
we're going to do this John you're gonna
walk across the street as you're walking
across the screen you're gonna say your
movie I'm gonna do the same thing don't
where to sit oh okay I don't know
exactly how this works walk past and say
the movie as you walk acid oh I have to
think first Jody got oh ok just see it
all okay well Atlanta's Greg told me to
easily Suicide Squad haha now we switch
chairs no Suicide Squad is one of the
worst things to come out this year mine
was lala land no I was all my might have
been lolla but there there are a couple
things like the invitation might be my
favorite movie of the year i'm not sure
i think when we were walking Billy Laine
and directed the directive gave us more
bars okay dear Billy you're so kind need
to make a night crawler movie they did
john f also know how do you think
episode is sorrows will turn out based
off the fact that i have seen so many
trailers for that movie and i've seen
plenty of behind-the-scenes footage and
have read the script I think he'll turn
out really well uh yeah just based on
Hollywood math I assume it'll be good
enough and now I just wonder how much
better than that it will be it's ryan
Johnson I trust him and I feel like they
might actually trust him to Harriet more
bars dude Harry is go broke donating to
us it'll be worth every penny trust me
movie genres horror hey Adam w thanks
Brendan the others a little competition
version today what is going on with the
bar situation the bars are out of
control this is like Trump selection
call the bar so
one's getting their law degree Adam w um
a lot of people have said Lady Gaga
should play poison ivy yeah I think
that's a great actually yeah I think
that's an amazing if you've seen her an
American Horror Story oh yeah she would
be a perfect choice for that one even
the little rule she's had like popping
up in like Robert Rodriguez flicks and
stuff like that like I don't know I I
enjoy and with daily they are solid
direction I'm sure she will do a great
job they gave him more than six weeks to
write that and they make like one or two
cuts instead of seven maybe that will
turn up okay there are a lot of requests
in your Facebook fan page for what for
what what what what yeah yeah yeah oh no
no no no you checking my facebook
messages but I don't know it's weird man
why are you checking his messages I
didn't reply back to that girl Sally met
this really cute girl the other day
named Sally John met her too she also
got a message from john she's not in
love with me Sid you still it's okay
it's okay if you can't donate I just
don't love you as much as you guys who
do today do you guys guess on your
broadcast I don't know what that means
the guests have someone like talk to us
we had Andrew tell you what well had no
no this guest suck you proposed are we
what's happening what does that mean
that you proposed Harriet are we getting
Harriet what does this mean are we
getting married are you serious about
this cuz if you're serious you can't you
can't take it back you can't just pull
out last minute we're gonna go all Billy
oh my god this is like an episode of The
Bachelor chai you both proposing to both
of us or you each proposing to one of us
I get Harriet okay I mean Billy seems
like a cool dude we can make my Harriet
is that cool Harriet I don't think
there's any way were where you wouldn't
I know I've competitive maybe we can
share them you can have Harriet on
Mondays Wednesdays and Fridays tuesdays
and thursdays i relax a little more
so I cannot be around Turk and she is
live wire maybe were you guys bothered
by Diego Lunas accent rogue one flights
no I was glad that you had it why is it
special getting this movie zeros are so
many different people I feel like the
Star Wars universe is the perfect
universe for literally any accent even
if it's [ __ ] up yeah like there's so
many planets and people I'm like yeah
I'm not distracted and release yeah you
know like that the people is so many
made up voices wow what is he what do
these proposals mean I mean are they
really proposing I don't know what that
means I think I should do it get married
to them get married to our subscribers
Tom Toni L wants to marry Tony you
didn't send an official proposal no ring
no thing which version of the nice guy
stars gerard butler and run rentals
happy new years from a haired head
Harriet oh my god ariat whoa feel that
chest oh I don't know why they haven't
invited us back on the road and I don't
know why it could just because they're
not paying until next year but yeah I
don't I don't get it hey you guys feel
about the rock lane Black Adam of the
new Shazam movie I feel like the rock is
long overdue to be miserable good movie
that's it this void oddly enough yet it
would if the one guy rambling how are
you not as you get a franchise man like
i know the fast abused is basically guys
oh my gosh so much love here tonight I
feel like most whoa Valerie see gravity
phone me back on its actually told all
of my sorority sisters and they thought
I was insane Valerie Valerie I followed
you back because he seemed like a really
kind sweet girl you're beautiful too
physically I'm sure you are internally
as well so you can tell all your
sorority sisters this guy gave you a
compliment and I hell I shot it shot
this photo yeah strange Billy to go
Valerie
sorority girls never met a sorority girl
girls actually in a sorority oh my girls
who have been in a sorority but never
like one who's in his room I've never
been a sorority girl inside of the
sorority house but I have met a sorority
girls out in public but then you're just
kind of a girl yeah it's true I feel
like they're just people at the end of
the day yeah it's weird thoughts on
Tarantino be done after his tenth film I
don't think he will stop I don't believe
him as cool as he wants to say that [ __ ]
I don't think he'll do it well my
hateful eight script colleagues I'm not
gonna make it what did he do yeah yeah I
feel like he wants to and I do feel like
I feel like he'll stop her maybe a few
years there's a while between Jackie
Brown and kill bill I feel like he'll
retire and then he'll pull like a
Michael Jordan were like every so often
he's like you know what I decided I
wanted to make a new film again and then
she's also said like I'm not gonna just
stop making [ __ ] at all he said he might
go do documentaries or something so guys
I think he'll cap out of like 13 and
nine ten listen a lot of people are
asking about what shows john and i watch
now when I tell you what show i just
finished you cannot put any spoilers
yeah down in the comment box because
john has not seen the latest season yet
ah Game of Thrones Oh finish all the way
up to season six and I want to shoot a
reaction to season 7 trailer I love that
show took me a few years to finally
start watching it it's one of the best
shows ever made Khaleesi please Khaleesi
I like this I like Game of Thrones I
gotta get the leg Drive up to watch it
again we will just watch westworld we
finished West robust robust amazeballs
that was one of the few shows were like
everyone lost their minds and I son I
was like I understand completely why
you've lost your mind yeah I have to UM
and then I thought it lanta was really
good Donald Glover show on FX and I'm
continuing from dusk till dawn season
three insecure I thought was really good
I saw one episode of man seeking woman
recently and that show made me giggle
like nobody's beeswax I just started
watching I just started continuing the
season 7 of walking dead that's all
right nothing's amazing imma watch the
season six and I i I've been catching
back up on black mirror too i just
watched a Christmas episode i ah amazing
but also I hasting a star black bear
black nears terrific and the seasons are
real short so how short the first
season's three episodes the second
season is three technically four because
they did like a Christmas episode that
just became and there are they're all
like different stories every episode
yeah every sort it's like The Twilight
Zone but an hour instead of a half hour
and order like it's it's like if you
liked westworld partly because of how
like sci-fi it is like black mirror
takes these like sci-fi concepts that
are like just in the near enough future
that you're like oh yeah I can see this
and it it really goes crazy with it okay
cool it's like oh yeah it's a special
show I think um would it be awesome if
Garfield and acquire made a cameo in
homecoming be distracting a seesaw so
weird it would be weird I don't think
they would agree to do it yeah I mean I
I don't know if then I just don't think
it would work I'd like don't think
they'd agreed to it you know oh well
that too I mean like maybe andrew
garfield I don't think so remember ya
think so i don't know maybe i don't
think it would work though um and i just
got an HBO now account and i want to
start i want to continue the surprise i
bought like the first three seasons
years ago and I just wanted to start
from season three again so I want to I
want to finish the soprano so even
though I know how it ends Toronto gets
shot to death in the restaurant
definitely that very very clear no room
for interpretation that you know it's
like you go yet blasted he dies his
family dices piranhas are all dead I
know I know it's not about be an
acceptor key right exactly like laws
come and I want to watch the wire as
well I want to start that up and I want
to watch deadwood yeah I won't devil it
I want six feet under
much cause I heard I heard oz is amazing
like Sopranos and odds were like the
launch of life [ __ ] HBO being drawn
you know I've always wanted to check out
um carnevale then show that they used to
do because i love that circus aesthetic
anyway yeah some like violent episodes
of like curb your enthusiam you know
yeah abbs really gritty like like a
Larry's cracks it like beat somebody to
die they're bringing back heard of your
enthusiasm I think that's another show
that will just not it will never go away
it'll just take a break for a while Toni
L sorry I just love that show yes we
have a checked out Atlanta and if you
all haven't uh go cuz it's a church I
haven't checked out Atlanta no y'all
[ __ ] were wasting your time do and
watching your walking dead's your games
of Thrones I think it like black mayors
I would tell people to make time for
Atlanta before walking to and I like
walking dead but I'm like hey check out
latest cuz Lana's something new to me
and and I that was again a show that I
started and I got really have done I I
thought it's terrific I can't wait to
see season two did you did I did we read
the game of thrones books the song a
fire nice yeah I've read every single
one of them I'm a quick reader that's a
hundred percent of the truth mhm have
you guys seen manchester-by-the-sea I
have not I'm a little conflicted about
that movie now just because of all the
casey affleck [ __ ] hey you want to know
what our most anticipated movies 2017
are well you're going to keep a look
after that video that we have yet to
show you where we shoot it at [ __ ]
though we'll shoot it opinions on negan
Greg what how do you feel about negan
now that you've continued the show so
i'm on episode five of season seven
right now okay and that's like I totally
i get everything they're doing with
negan and I get that he's supposed to be
like ridiculously charismatic but it's
kind of to the point where it feels a
little hammy okay it feels a little
cartoony like I get you're honoring me
in the comments yes
sarandon from the comics you need to aya
logs specifically from the car and
that's that's all well and done and the
writing of him is good and all but
there's something that feels a little
underwhelming about it and I can't quite
pinpoint it I haven't seen a season 7
but entertain a question would it may be
because the I often wonder about season
7 from everything I've heard from people
because the season's premiere is so huge
and is that is it just too big for the
rest of the season to really deliver
well what I'm kind of like a little
bothered by oh I'm only on the fifth
episode now I don't even seen the fifth
episode / yeah well I'm kind of bothered
by how there is so much build-up to mean
you get 10 minutes of him in season 6
the whole first episodes like
practically dedicated him and the third
and fourth episode feature a heavy
amount of negan it's to the point where
I'm like he can kind of feels like the
star of the show down and yeah like a
little too much nicon for me like I know
them the audiences love me again but
it's not gonna like me yeah I don't want
to like feel like he's the main
character oh yeah get that I hear I hear
you most unappreciated film of the year
go what do you think what do you think
what nice guys dude [ __ ] yeah the nice
guys is amazing i would say nice guys is
the most unappreciated film in terms of
the territory that it was in fairly
expensive not like hugely expensive but
decently expensive it's a studio film
will too big a-list actors isn't a
mid-range that's going away that often
produce yeah pretty cool movies you know
yeah exactly and you know like it should
have it did I don't think it made that
much money and I felt like it should
have like if you're looking from like
hell or high water which is an indie
drama not a studio film like that was a
very appreciated film and nice guys
probably made more money than that film
but I still feel like nice guys is the
more under I feel like that's the one
that's being greatly overlooked yeah you
don't hear anyone talking about it for
like any serial you're more about people
not about Deadpool being considered
right oh my god I'm like where the
[ __ ] the nice guys
yeah man I thought the nice guys was
terrific like the nice guys was a breath
of fresh air and it really enthralled me
and it stuck with me and I do i I do
agree I've heard a couple people say
this and I saw the movie so I think it's
on the money out I thought pop star was
pretty underrated I mean I I thought
that movie was really really funny and
it kind of came and went and I feel bad
for that and I think hopefully it'll be
kind of like hot rod were like it finds
its audience over time but yeah hey we
got some bar so Johnny who donated I
wanted believes how Tony now go back cuz
this thing goes in order for most
parcels bars Tony Tony Tony out Tony
honey whatever tony donates I'm gonna
quote Terrence Howard from Iron Man 1
hey Tony watch iron man 1 again they're
gonna be like that's how he says Tony
Tony a real quick John and I were
talking about this yesterday I prefer
Terrence Howard as as rho d / / Don
Cheadle just so you guys know I thought
I should put that out there he thought I
should try to inspire the MCU to recast
off their Terrance about her I get what
you mean I mean I like Don Cheadle in
general but but yeah it wasn't it wasn't
until civil war and like you know part
way through civil war that I thought
like Don she'll actually did some like I
don't know like they gave him something
member like you know he got a chance to
have a character beat it was like oh
yeah like he's memorable beyond just you
know being a side character he
I don't know about that not not not
insofar as it made me love him but like
it did a little bit for for life okay I
was like finally I ok I get why I have
done sheetal here like you know um be a
Terrence Howard leg is I do think he was
a good roadie and I'm bummed that he
didn't get to come back so there's your
answer I good yeah that's true all right
you have to take one more question to
write a call it a night looking for a
question that's what all the silence
always staring is I'm sorry I can't do
anything don't be sorry Oh most over
rated film of the year great quite most
over it what is the most over rated film
of the year Oh Tarantino hurry to sounds
hard but I would take Tarantino uh
what's the what's the most over rated
film of the year was the film that was
love that wasn't what that was like it's
good I don't love it as much as everyone
else all right um over rated film of the
year this is the promise like you get to
the end of the year and you're like what
all of I see especially front like we
see a lot of movies in a year and it
does become a fascinating experiment cuz
by the end you do have to look some of
them up and there's stuff that yeah what
did uh what was underwhelming well
someone says Deadpool someone says
finding dory I guess he finding Dory
possibly be no rib a BC rennes autoroute
it's really it's over he is overhyped
yeah I mean like it's overrated but not
in the real way John Valerie said thank
you guys for the compliment you're both
looking at my sorority house anytime a
lot of hot girls where is this sorority
where what city country are you talking
about Valerie chance tipis a thousand
bart chance
you're the reason we take chances in
life you can't grow without stepping
outside of your comfort zone what do I
follow you gotta you gotta go check out
chance chance see Valerie the C stands
for [ __ ] as well every time I didn't see
the word seats ton chance that [ __ ]
that's what means a pic of a chip yeah I
can't think about that i might say
finding dory cuz it got like amazing
amazing reviews and then I watched it
I'm like it was alright like I didn't
think it was this spectacular film uh
yeah yeah watch it I didn't see it I I
would have to look up what what movies I
saw I'm trying to think did did any what
came out this year Valerie you're all
the way in Seattle well help donate bar
so you can fly John and I out to meet
some hot girls and said I want to visit
seattle for lumps I went to Seattle I
did tough mudder over there I did tough
mudder guys well Valerie will consider
it thank you for being so kind of
opening your door sorority chicks yeah
thanks to you know one guest does that
mean quiz I'm you can we look at this
gap you where I'm making you a guest oh
alright we're going to talk this room oh
dude y'all we're here for this yeah
we're here let's see how this guest
stuff works what's up dude what's up man
hmm hey is it going you gotta for your
future years you've been watching
YouTube for years whatever eyes tears oh
thank you thank you why are you only
showing half your face to us are you
shocked you have a nice ear thank you
you're like this horror movie villain
thing thanks um yeah I'm a nerd as you
well know that all your walls [ __ ]
that does not
usually by the camera face kami they
start my small since many of your videos
I have like a lot of girls like that I
like a lot of people acting I don't live
in California but can you guys give me
advice like I really want to do acting
like I'm really interested in
auditioning for the ben affleck movie as
Damian Wayne and I live in Michigan so I
don't know how that happened I mean to
get an audition for something like that
we know the rules of how that works you
gotta like usually to get it a film for
like the bad man baby you gotta have an
agent who yeah you gotta who already has
credibility and you have credibility as
well where they can get you into a
special audition like that unless they
do like one of those harry potter things
were like we go to London have an open
call Cass yeah but I we need a yeah you
got work your way up to like something
major like that otherwise John and I
would audition for the Ben Affleck
Batman we're at it yeah I could easily
be in the next rob zombie film tomorrow
and it starts by showing your face to us
now if you want to be confident of their
way of God yeah yeah yeah that's a sexy
[ __ ] now shut your mouth shut
your mouth unless you're trying to like
protect your identity in which case like
this oh yeah oh yeah there's that smile
there you go come on yeah yeah you got
bring that ass from Michigan over to
cali ladies will eat that ass up what's
up girls down here I'll go to lick your
ass we're here to build you're confident
what time is it in Michigan oh like two
is that way morning in yrs are you
implying something up click two in the
morning two in the morning well you're
up late that's really cool man hey we're
gonna take one more guest since we're
getting like two or more people coming
in we got take a couple more guests but
thank you for taking time to talk with
us thank you no problem well I miss your
face one more time
please yeah sup sexy yeah you know like
we now can you just do like one can you
show it to us what Joe it to us hey
there you go yeah I'm proud of you
Harriette L we're gonna talk to Harry
here we go just a hobbit from New
Zealand oh wow we're guessing this is
where guesting is huh that's what this
that's what they tell me ok aakasam
don't worry we're gonna hit you up in a
second August sons here we're back to
Michigan what would happen to Harriet
Harriet where have you gone hi are you
there are we speaking to right now have
shockingly similar wall post that's
amazing area because scale replica this
guy's play God I don't think I don't
think she's there or else something is
wrong with you now this could be guys is
there like a switchboard I don't know I
we were trying to talk to Harriet
touched a chance for tipping 500 more
bars Harriet we're gonna try you again
in a second but first let's see if
August on will talk to us up the Sun
real isn't the internet amazing Arkansas
we could talk to you here it's the
technology is amazing from Japan to LA
the real rejects Anaka son connect once
again I love it how you boys doing
tonight one of my favorite sketches is
still the one we did with you ah yes yes
I could not legit feedback from you on
that and by the way I liked it I liked
that it was it was um it was interesting
to actually do a skit like that and you
actually legitimately did
scare me when I said the name ryan right
and your life don't you ever say that
name again don't you ever say you
legitimately scared me on that one so
yeah but it was gone your camera work is
crappy camera get her fix it yeah I got
it good that was my my first time on the
job doing the gonzo style type stuff so
you know for those of the kids I don't
know gonzo will explain another time
yeah so what time is it over there uh
it's about 420 ironically it's about 420
over here right now morning yeah yeah
yeah all of those locks green my boy
wait no weeds legal now i scoped 22 weed
guys that's just me Jeff yes we all are
we are all about that Greg so I was
actually up here editing my top 10 top
five movies of 2006 and I think I lost
the entire project but I saw you guys
streaming so you know if you say we
consider making top movies of 2006 top
but I did it again goddammit top movies
of 2016 so I I'm from the future or the
past now I'm gonna go back and do like
retroactively top 10 lists like what
would a bit 100 movies of 1983 not would
that would because I saw you guys
actually did one as well I was watching
a little bit of it there um and I saw
that you guys were trying to recast the
Joker goddamn you yep best video but I
believe every comment was incredibly
positive on them yeah that was it was
quite funny like I i'd personally did
like the portrayal but you know um that
that was particularly me so you know wow
awesome I don't see why like I don't
know why there are things about it that
I do well here's look my hair is my main
point is the fact that the Joker isn't
really supposed to be funny if you got
if you cringed there
into Joker scenes then he did his job
because the job the Joker is supposed to
make you feel uncomfortable and make you
feel like you're not in control of the
situation and I felt that's what Leto
was trying to portray there well that's
something that I wondered about
especially seeing it the second time I
was like this is kind of it like I am
repelled by this character which right
that's the point yes like I see this
guide I'm like you're not supposed to be
in love with him you're actually
supposed to be kind of disgusted turned
off afraid of him so that's kind of see
where what little was coming where
little was coming from had it been
ridden a little bit better and worked
into the scenes made a little more
intricate I think people would have
enjoyed it a lot more but because it was
kind of just like bonus footage people
it gave a good excuse for people not to
enjoy it so my opinion why definitely
hurts it's like you can tell that those
scenes were cut down and like yeah
character doesn't matter so like it's
yeah I'm working against that bat
portrayal to begin with were you like
yeah it's like very this awkward thing
of like okay now what do we do like you
know it's only yeah I'm sorry I am so
tired and I all these guests on because
i just realized i remember you showed me
how to guests with people when i
remembers this and I just figure out how
to do it now there are people who
donated bars that we feel compelled
where people pleasers you know go where
go where the money is sir go where the
money is I understand I should have bet
that I mean myself but it's good to see
you guys uh one more time before the end
of 2016 it's only been about four months
since we got together and such Harris
your nipples you should show me yours
sir yes why you know damn yeah you know
what that was that was a little too
easier that way too easy I will show you
I will show you my shield though but
i'll show you my new captain of it
christmas
oh that's big dad there you go man
that's that's that's that's all you get
today you copy yeah yeah sorry I k I
don't want to undo my bra here so yeah
it's okay it's okay guys Mary rivers I
mean happy new year happy new year okay
namaste [ __ ] yeah all right his
piece [ __ ] oh are you trying Harriet
home we're time it Harriet just you know
if you're a girl you're more likely to
be talk to you right now cuz we talk to
you guys hey I'm like Wi-Fi tether oh my
god there you order is she talking to me
she talking to you do we have it are you
there I think we got a lag issue I'm hey
we're trying to talk to you but it's
lagging so much you sound like a rabbit
you sound like a Greek it's lagging some
about look well tell you what we think
about you while we can kind of seen it
hello hello Harriet Harriet Harriet how
are you there Harriet Harriet Harriet
talk to me talk to us Harriet we're
trying to get your attention I like your
posters ah what do you Perry it you're
just frozen right now no or she is just
giving us a blank reaction and things
for do it what a one of the two is going
on right now or is that or is that a
vape all right here we're gonna try you
again in one second yeah we're gonna
make this work we promise we swear it
all right let's try Valerie see Valerie
Valerie we're gonna try hey
oh my god you guys have no idea what it
like texting all my friends right now
and I'm like you guys like I'm am the
real deal right now the great we have
your life right to e nothing gets better
than this mode are you right now I have
how are you pretty good have you been to
California before I have but not
recently you grew up in Seattle no I
grew up in Mexico oh wow I like mexican
on a big fan of the mexican are you
second time I'm a man of all people I'm
primarily a big fan of mexican people
that was good we learned a conversation
starter okay what is your passion that's
what you asked what is your passion in
life out what is your passion I mean
like my passion is kind of different
from what I'm actually doing something
like I don't know I feel like answering
of it I don't know I mean like I'm like
no no no tell us through I should just
tell us your heart be true okay um
probably superheroes or dancing one of
the two all I know yeah what kind of
dancing yeah um I do ballet hell yeah so
you must be a very beautiful in person
la yeah i mean like my parents like put
me through all that [ __ ] when I was
little so like ballet figure skating
gymnastics wash you're like really
athletic hey I guess I mean I don't
really do it that much anymore after
college started so that happens I I do
30 minutes of cardio him yeah I mean I I
try maybe like once a month probably
miss do you miss not do it do you miss
doing it more yeah cuz like all my
friends are still doing it who are still
like in high school so I just likes the
older Instagram post I'm like oh missing
out ja do you feel like we're trying to
come across a little cooler cuz she's
pretty I kind of feel that happening
right now you know
oh no I'm sorry I'm like not wearing
makeup right now 11 you look at once
thank John tell her the truth she looks
beautiful you look lovely you look
beautiful see how let's bring finally
more coffee with women if their way
across the other side to find a little a
small oh yeah pics Liriano can you have
to look at them directly in the eye we
can just tell them we're going over
great we're all really go ahead we don't
have to think about where to put our
arms or anything like I focus to him
yeah thank God for the lot huh no I'm
blanking out again John ask her a
question party okay quick most
underrated movie of the year are you
excited for suicide ah what was the
biggest disappointment of my life and I
was like my best friend was like oh yeah
like it got terrible ratings sounds like
I'm still going like I'm still going to
see it and they were like okay but it's
really really bad and then I was like no
it couldn't be good and then I went in
and I came out and I was like I hate
myself there is no global erc theory of
critics who just hate suicide squads
it's not very do you have a boyfriend
terrible no there's a question what's
your favorite do you have a boyfriend no
okay okay now the game changer I'm
rather date me your job go answer now
like both at the same time like that can
happen uh we don't we don't double team
like that we need to choose one of us
okay well that's a bummer like I mean I
can't right now how many one met you
guys in real life she shows you John
probably choose no no no I'm the fat
funny one you're the good looking
there's a good-looking white dude oh
look at me I'm a hipster I got on my
diet here my glasses yeah
if you are planning ahead they're gonna
want to laugh all the Valerie's choose
you in the end John talking about Donna
hasn't even followed me back on
Instagram so I'm I know but that I why
you're more attracted him because he's
like oh he's playing like he's making
you chase him this is how i do it hard
to get on if you're a he doesn't go
after you go after him that's what
John's game it's working on you listen
which one's your Instagram her name is
Valerie see something I think that was
helping it's broken great smile of her
it's good it's the best place to freeze
vow that we can't put favoritism for too
long okay down in Siberia as much as
we're having fun with trying to get you
and John together pretty I I have to we
have like a few other people we got to
talk to you as well but are so nice
putting a wonderful face like to seeing
your presence your personality your
alright nice gorgeous human being and it
shows wrong you chose wrong but they
chose wrong that's me okay okay how do
you guys say have a good night good luck
bye all right Harriet all right Harry
ever give you one last shot one more
shopper Harriet it's a fun dog in the
fan don't worry guys you see you other
people will get to you guys Bobby's been
working Harriet please Vic Wales hello
hello hello we can hear you Harry is it
working I want this works i really
wanted me Gary I really miss wicks is it
was it's like almost kind of worried
it sounds like in poltergeist when she's
like still on the other side of the
world it kind of messages you're
drafting the TD yeah Carolina it sounds
exactly like barely hear it Oh Harriet
you have a gorgeous smile wait yeah
whatever that motion you're doing is
Wonder Boy can out that's not what she
has an accent yeah she's a new woman I
like your posters I'm sorry I want to
know this and like shaking oh it's okay
don't worry don't I can't even see you
shaking yeah this is this is the beauty
as we can kind of hear you and so part
of the pressure is off but you do have a
lovely you're frozen on like us are you
were frozen I like a smile so that was
those cool now she's frozen annoyance
like why am I talking to you good now
you look silly it's still like frozen
but it's okay that's really all right
Harriet before the night is over we're
gonna try you one more time organized
watch the prove your connection area so
think a second I can hear your total
voice and now you're that you're rizal
yeah we want to talk we just can't make
anything sending all your souls out and
like jumbled up you know tech techno
robot thing maybe i'll give you John's
phone number you can call them directly
there you go really oh I just kids like
breaks my heart because all you hear is
like already helping them [ __ ] like no
you're nothing the only saving grace is
it like you know we're not on some kind
of doom space hot like my phone Arabic
all right
try you again if you hit wrong at six at
my prize we will all right let's try it
other dude who donated here he's got
them donations and your flick freaks
wants to chat with us so we'll get to
you flick freaks will get to you ok
let's do scott jenkins done it a lot
here the bill and bora will make sure
you you gasps with show alright let's
start this you see scott jenkins 98 is
more than your 1990 god jinxiu 18 years
old let's do this the jank connecting
connecting its connecting texting flight
school Jenkins man hey hey how you doing
I'm super hella late here in Oregon I'm
in the bathroom where if one sleeper are
you [ __ ] no let's set thank you for
verifying that fact though nvidia
problem just a request so i finally have
facebooks and your friend request please
Ski Santa again he wants you to send him
a friend request on facebook send a
friend cut well let's see if we can be
friends first let's not wait for enzymes
that what I mean that gave me a lot of
how popular you right now in your life
oh I'm very talkative but i'm hella
tired because I I need to know like deep
okay so uh how many close friends do you
have oh I have poly about oh I just 55
is a good number five numbers like Mary
5 is a good number is close and it's
just in my bubble basically my friend
bubble hey go do you have a girlfriend
no what no I I did but it didn't last
that long gotcha I've been there my
friend I've been there plenty oh yeah
it's really bad when your family makes
it worse they just don't like make make
them comfortable or nothing like that
makes them uncomfortable
yes also let's get real here that's
what's changed the vibe of this old live
stream what happened thank you huh what
happened you know oh well my dad gave me
like 40 bucks cuz I'm broke and he said
go go up with her hook up with her and I
ended up hanging out with her to rest of
the night but she said it was
uncomfortable cuz she knew my dad was
involved Oh how'd she know that because
she's his roommate didn't try to flip my
desk ah yeah she's a little too old for
me anyway she's like 23 I just graduated
this year you're 18 I mean yeah that
sounds like a bit of a tricky situation
being are you again but yeah yeah don't
worry I lost my virginity at 18 / you so
I'm not that far behind I guess you were
20 when you watched your virginity I was
18 hey man and this guy's got way more
action than I've ever gotten amen and
then come well thank you so much man I
have to go to like go to sleep because
everyone's asleep I don't want with
money hey a good sleep schedule is
everything yeah we've been say we're
going to end this stream for about 40
minutes now so we know what it's like 40
here where is the same time zone so like
you use those out doesn't go bars to use
man you have a good one yeah you ever go
12 and stuff man look some weed not no
more hi guys did I have a good night
with you up good night he wrote the
villain comin up here of the villain
coming up we'll only talk to people who
donated bars we all need is an exception
yo yo yo here the villas done this is it
like the afternoon where are you oh I'm
the guy from San Diego here in San Diego
why is the daytime in San Diego oh you
got away right there
alright dude you're what what is Bobby
you got like a cool collection of stuff
Thor Batman spider-man hell yeah holy
crap did you just set that up for us to
live stream with us my room bro this
mission is good Greg's got that bottle
poster you're not a bad-looking guy
question question from the 90th to now
with you guys is favorite food trilogy
any genre Lord trilogy trillion I would
say the Lord of the Rings trilogy Bowl
the Rings I better than Farrakhan matrix
no it's not my favorite blah well damn
it I have to contemplate Lord of the
Rings is a more solid trilogy of films
however the matrix I mean you do love
the story to its conclusion I feel like
the matrix is one of those trilogies
that you have to watch at least a couple
times to fully grasp the grand scope of
everything I want to rewatch the trilogy
I do i do but i feel like lord of the
rings of the most perfectly crafted
trilogy uh i have two answers for this
question because i am a gemini uh but
the one of these is going to be less
satisfying the other and this is a true
answer the before series is one of my
favorite trilogies before midnight
before sunrise before sunset and before
midnight blue ink later movies with
ethan hawke and julie delpy are
wonderful and on the other half of that
coin i would go with human centipede
just because uh because there something
weird i appreciate about the human
centipede the Cornetto trilogy count oh
[ __ ] it's the Cornetto trilogy shaun of
the dead hot fuzz in world's end hell
yeah oh yeah those are good even though
we human scent of people who told you
yeah yeah it's a very weird trilogy but
they all connect to each other in a
weird met a kind of way and if you if if
that's your bag then go watch the yeah
here in the village you smoke weed ok be
one [ __ ] you
you seem like a cool dude you know I
thought you were sipping on some stone I
live lien--a back so if you guys all
come down to show you got some breweries
or something you know do yeah we do ya
next time we're in San Diego if I love
San Diego I love ah what's up it's
alright it's not that great we're gonna
put I gotta mention when you now relax
when you live in place special if you
live in California through the best
place either cuz we got the beach not a
lot of people have the beach we got TJ
tacos down the street fire ma'am please
touch it's okay it's almost midnight
here you should be over tomorrow what do
you was your job or 150 right I work for
Amazon do you pilot a drone look you
like drop a package on the job I'm a
delivery guy over everyone okay huh see
your those [ __ ] you keep delivering
to the wrong door step cookie watching
purposely notice that you missed me you
specifically it's you you keep leaving
era martes a contribution to my problems
hey man forever down san diego will make
an announcement you gotta meet up with
us okay I'm gone wrong what's your real
name Robin can you tell us your real
name grief Reese Louise event with
Mexican the st. Louis Arena Oh Lewis if
Coleman Reese isn't dead in it happening
it's nice to meet you Luis it's nice to
meet you Luis forever down San Diego
will let you know shea butter is cheers
to you sir you seem like a really cool
deal together sometime so how do you
want
alright what they have your mom say hi
to your mother like Mark Wahlberg stay
all right last guy Borat to do this and
then we'll say hi to flick freaks I've
always wanted to meet that guy hell yeah
pick up or at moms be pick up or at just
this is really not a good time did you
ask if this is a bad time I'm kind of in
the middle of are you taking your your
middle of an orgasm did he say is in the
middle of an orgasm no I think he said
he's in the bathroom I could see a shout
yep you are lagging my friend and you
are just coming up with sexual words
this is done you're having a good time I
think you said isn't that easy freaking
I'm not a good time I'm sorry I think
he's mad at us for accepting his
requests to talk to guests with him but
hey I mean like this is a life moment
though like you know embrace it let's go
on a journey okay keep trying to scare
me i think we should say bye he was a
man and a shot yeah it wasn't a time
he's dead and a call to her on film
maybe like five minutes or you to cut it
up yes I'm in the middle of your very
busy right now alright we understand
yeah yeah no we don't want any trouble
video a shovel over no my troubles I
will figure this what's hot what's locks
in yeah well fuxored cheese there's that
mustache oh hello I was just reading a
book bricks I was gonna break you guys
doing our sir i'm doing alright how
about you I'm doing good what is your
ethnicity
I'm Scandinavian oh nice yeah all right
i'll take you to grow that mustache
urien as you can possibly be I mean you
do do look like like a white guy where
where do you live cuz I saw you did
videos with Tyra I'm in Springfield
Missouri and i flew up to a lil adelphia
to collaborate with him so why have you
can apply maroon his cool guy yeah is
this sweetie yeah he's all right uh why
haven't you uh who are good you what why
aren't you flown to California so we can
collab I am a next November I'm going to
LA for their critics choice awards so
whenever I do that we got to do some
collaborating while I'm down there how
will you go into their critics choice
awards that we haven't even received an
invitation are even I'm a critic so then
are you like a critic or other formats
besides YouTube yeah yeah there's a news
station that I work for I'm like on the
red team they're like a bunch of Film
Critics get together and we decide what
the best movies to see in theaters are
so that's pretty cool bit of like a top
100 films like the year and stuff so
it's a lot of fun I think it'll I your
trailer phony I've seen a lot of your
trailer we ask you for freedom was it
lucky duck as you know I've seen a lot
of your trailer reactions and I think I
really like that you give like
insightful opinions like you actually
review as well and I think I tried
honestly the reason why I started doing
it was because the very first reaction i
saw was yours to Godzilla back in 2014 I
think so Oh back in the day we made
history yeah great flick freaks with the
flake freaks we made his it's all your
fault no this has happened d yes how
many sins we are responsible how many
subscribers are you at right now i am at
34 and a half thousand i think somewhere
around there
you were not all you can do it again a
year and a half so that's really it's
better than what we had in here to
happen really yet that's that's really
good yeah I'm pretty excited I'm trying
to be the number one subscribe youtuber
in my city right now number two so I do
you will get yeah I prob as you will do
I don't know what's in front of me but
as soon as I take care of him good I
don't know this movie is a full of
youtubers the most popular ones the nice
channel that you got there it's a shame
of something were to happen it's exactly
what I was linkage area I was curious
what did you guys pick is like your
number one movie of 2016 I chose la la
land I'm still debating but that's one
of my pops you know that's your number
channeling his number two yeah what's
your never rivals number one okay what
was great yeah yeah that's definitely
like in my top 10 but it's not it's not
like i would say lala land and the nice
guys alright awesome really did ya
switch swiss army man might have been my
favorite movie this year I have Swiss
Army a man at number 21 on my list as a
go you to be yeah you said top 100 right
yeah top 100 yeah what's number one
hundred number 100 I got a scroll down
here you guys have iphones there's a
really cool app that ranks all your
movies and stuff that you see throughout
the year what is it letterbox d yeah
yeah yeah I haven't I have a gun to use
as much as i would like but i have i did
download it here I want to remember all
the stuff I see them here that's exactly
it so I got a preface since you said
number 100 obviously once you get
further down the list of movies get x
criminally shittier so number one
hundred right now is Ninja Turtles out
of the shadow I what didn't make the
list past 100
is gods of Egypt brothers Grimsby
monster Angry Birds snow in the Huntsman
and shallows oh you'd like the shallows
I didn't like shallows oh I really like
the shower I really oh no it was the
only person that hated that movie is
much or as much as like anybody else
like but that was okay but I didn't hate
it is what everybody was saying like
suicide squad I saw a review retire out
on that movie ah Suicide Squad man that
was no suicide squad right now is number
6 D so it was hate it but it was
definitely i'm kind of disappointed by
DC right now every single time I think
about it the Wonder Woman could be the
first really good DC movie yeah we say
the same thing about every year if we
keep saying it though eventually we're
gonna be right yeah like mathematically
so they will make a completely good
movie one day they suffer loss of the
universe and energy if we keep directing
that energy they might absorb it and
make a good movie I would be thrilled if
Wonder Woman was there really good well
like I would love that i don't i'm a
little worried about it but it would be
great if you're like I think once i get
to Gotham sirens they might get it down
that's that's when they'll point may
have an idea of what they're going for
into DC EU David air going through
little golden age and then they're gonna
make one good movie they're gonna go
through like every single story they
possibly can Bhagat hope so yeah you
said you're coming out here in November
yeah that's the plan or that the Critics
Choice Awards this year was in November
but I didn't go so next year i'm
probably going to go and if it's in
november again who knows I might I might
make a trip out to LA before then though
so it's more than possible I'll be cool
what by the time you get to November how
many subscribers do you want to be yet
let us take a look at good old
socialblade future projections
and november i am predicted to have your
mathematical game 77 no 80,000 80,000 is
what I'm projected to happy get to a
hundred thousand do it I thinking is
general under compras good that pun
below I think you deserve it I think you
have great content I think you have
really good opinions to appreciate it
thank you so much that means a lot
considering you two are the main reason
why i started doing this so i appreciate
that thank you stop or i'll show you my
[ __ ] he will i will happen out it's only
fair if you show then i gotta show him
and i will lost the both of it I haven't
taken a shower today so this is gonna be
awkward and so okay realism that's what
we like I haven't shaved in four years
so it's going to be okay mine is
constantly assisted by that like and
make it younger CGI so it's like
pristine all times in a little fake
looking that is a pretty uncanny valley
dick if I've ever seen one that's the
kind of dick i want this is uncanny
valley UT valley dicks nothing that's
gonna be the name of my new metal band
oh yeah i will bye every album i'll get
t-shirt so John when I have to finish
with we try wrapping up our livestream
about 45 minutes we just didn't get
around to it we have to finish a product
placement alright have to submit that
under his boss smoke with yeah we have
to go edit it and submit it to them and
it's midnight for us yeah so we got a 10
to that but dude when you're out here
please let us not do before we chatter
on Twitter right yeah I'm gonna I'll
send you like a private message was like
my contact info and stuff so cool sounds
good sounds good that's meeting man how
can you guys you take it easy all right
yeah take it easy brother the next time
hey captain
alright well let's give some shout out
who we still got we got 49 people's
gonna watch shitty people okay chance
cooked you are the number chance cook
you are the number one most donated make
sure you get his name down all you guys
are donated today Harriet Lane sorry the
conversations didn't work out we'll try
Brendan me dude your lovely human being
Rodney 7 um you are the danger to my
field Tony Liam you are the you're
sexier than Tony Stark wow how many
people is hard hard hello hawker 20 30
to alright guys we gotta call it a night
we actually got to do it this time yeah
we would stay on here all night if we
could thank you for tuning in we are the
real rejects uploads we'll be robbing
again tomorrow you better believe